hi my name is markiplier and I'm about
to drink this 5 million Scoville hot
sauce again but before I do that I
actually have some information to give
you guys I want to do vlog but not
normally so I'm going to pax tomorrow
flying out in the morning I'm going
straight to Boston and to hang out with
Wade Bob yamimash and jacksepticeye
we're all going to be there we're all
going to have a ton of fun
Bob Wade and I will be doing the panel
on Friday I think it's at 1:00 or 1:30
there's more information that will come
later if you want to find out all of the
details of what's going on at PAX and
keep up-to-date with what's going on
while we're there follow me on Facebook
and Twitter if you're not already the
information is in the description below
and while we're there we're going to be
meeting up with all of you guys as much
as we can but we don't know if we're
going to be doing an outdoor Meetup you
just don't know at that point we don't
know the area and frankly it's probably
cold there because they had record
amounts of snow but other than that
while I'm gone I will only be able to
upload one video a day mostly because
five nights of Grundy's through
everything for a loop I recorded
everything I even got the good ending
done but those videos I have to pace
them out just because unfortunately I
didn't have time to record anything else
but in addition to that I wanted to
introduce you guys to my good buddies
who are holding the camera right here
daniel and ryan from cyndago they've
helped me out a great deal on making
sketches and they're just totally normal
guys with no works at all but together
we made our first sketch possible while
we're here
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
all our configurations will being my
name is Wilfer worth hatching tonight I
bring you the interview of all
interviews my triumph ever heard a
hard-hitting girl I'd like to welcome my
special guest had a security a Freddy
fazbear pizza
phone guy welcome sir hello good so
that's all the information that I wanted
to do now to kill ourselves
are you ready kids we are ready hi
captain just gonna yeah okay go ahead
you're gonna go first aren't sure people
people in the audience are like no no
those two guys really to be safe we're
only going to do a tiny itty bitty itty
bitty amount because these guys are not
up for hot stuff I suck dealing yeah
they had a video on their channel where
we tried the last hot sauce that we did
and cheers there buddy oh you want to
see know you we got to get this in
detail yeah can you see this is just
such - this is just the end of a
chopstick yeah worth a high amount it's
gonna really not be fun okay II it's a
big house such a tiny all right quick I
can own it I got it I'm sorry I can't
wait you I'll get it I'll get it right
there
yeah just said no no that's too much
wait do a little less than that little
bit that's good okay go
no you're foreseeably oh yes he Daniel
Daniel for some rain is very eager to do
all this and I don't know why then again
I have to because hey why not you're
right there you're right there right
maybe remember last time / - like 20
bits for me to start Nick you know are
you feeling good
what's up man not bad no yeah it's not
fun I'm actually doing okay like after
that first hit okay I think I write too
much of all oh you want to get more yeah
I'll do a little more I can are you okay
you're teared up
pinger we gonna get this up here me I
like I don't deal oh man this is greasy
other than warming to you yeah I know I
should thank you
this whole vlog shouldn't have been done
in the first place I know stupid idea
but a good foot to selfie cam just a bit
positive put this over here okay we're
back alright so hey how you doing guys
still crying yeah okay I'm just gonna
keep a corn and get till it gets to the
point where we can't take it anymore or
actually have to say goodbye because I
have to go edit more videos it's burning
hot no yeah are you looking your face
not okay let's face it someone who's not
okay I did this in uh oh I am Brad yes I
played this with iron bread and it is a
ones that call again please tell us uh
is gonna meet your maker and it is nice
to meet him it is five million Scoville
hot sauce oh I guess we're going with
the built so cheers everybody
but anyway thank you guys so much
these guys are gonna be a pax but expect
a lot more sketches like the one you're
gonna see this weekend on Saturday I
think in the future and look out for all
the great videos we're going to be
making within four more really
constantly they will be run over me cuz
they live here down we're here so they
got plates right our place oh yeah I
forgot these this is your place that was
great how it's so entertaining they just
moved in so thank you everybody again
and as always we'll see you in the next
video bye